millions of videogame fans around the
world are getting their first look this
morning at the new season of fortnight
Battle Royale
the wildly popular multiplayer game is
described by some as minecraft Meets
Hunger Games and fans are really into it
it's the booming video game craze with
millions of players celebrating the
sweet taste of victory or facing the
bitter agony of defeat in the shooting
game fortnight battle royale players are
dropped onto an island where they fight
to be the last man or woman standing the
game is free but players can pay for
accessories to make their battles more
colorful including costumes and even
dance moves for their characters and
that translates into big revenue for
developer epic games in March alone
fortnight reportedly brought in two
hundred and twenty three million dollars
the game which rewards building skills
as much as marksmanship has also
propelled the careers of popular video
game streamers like Tyler Blevins aka
ninja with more than six million
followers ninja broadcasts himself
playing fortnight on the popular site
twitch his exploits are viewed by tens
of thousands of viewers a day in March
ninja teamed up with rappers Drake
Travis Scott and NFL wide receiver juju
Smith Schuster breaking twitch streaming
records more than 600,000 people tuned
in for their battle release of the new
season also solved one of fortnight's
burning mysteries a comet had recently
appeared in the sky causing anxiety and
discussion among players about the
comments meaning we have the answer it
crashed down on the island's dusty depot
which has appropriately been renamed
dusty divot sparing tilting towers Dan
Ackerman from our partners at CNET is
with us good morning Dan morning guys so
explain to people who are going huh why
this game has caught on and become so
obsessive for those who are interest I
think they've hit a bunch of key thing
the game is free you know it's fun it's
fairly easy to get started and you can
also get it pretty much anywhere on your
computer on your xbox your PlayStation
and I can get it on your iPad or your
iPhone so they've knocked down a lot of
the barriers that might keep people from
trying it out 233 million dollars Black
Panther in its first full month that it
was open made I think 219 just to give
people some context how are they making
the money if it's not to play the game
yeah when you have the game for free
this battle royale version of the game
people feel more comfortable spending a
little bit of money here and there for
some extra stuff like different costumes
and things and the big package you could
buy for every season it's about $10 it's
not a big investment so I think that
they get a lot of people to to pony up
for a little bit of extra because they
feel like they're not paying upfront
like $60 for the game there's also a
huge social aspect of this as well and
that's really the key it's not so much
the game itself although the game is fun
it's the fact that your friends are
playing it your family members are
playing and you hear about it at work
and you get this social utility from the
shared experience and every once in a
while something comes along whether it's
a game or a TV show like Game of Thrones
where everyone is doing it at the same
time and you have to be part of that
conversation I certainly know in my own
family that is the case although my
daughter when she caught me playing was
really embarrassed and had to leave the
room our contributor at CBS News
contributor and psychologist Lisa
d'amour wrote in The Times that for
tonight is quote built to be addictive
what's your take on that as the as the
parent of a young gamer I mean I see
what games do but also other forms of
technology other screentime activities
even watching youtube videos this game
was intended for you know kids 13 and up
and adults but any kind of game I see
kids play Mario Kart or anything on the
switch and it's something you know if
you have to set screen time limits a lot
of new technology comes with parental
controls so you can say after an hour
it'll shut off I shouldn't listen when
when my kids say let me just finish this
game let them finish that one and then
and then pull the plug I I had this
fight every night but also if you die
early then you haven't really finished
the game you really got to read up and
then really have a
Gudrun before you feel completely
finished dan Ackerman John Dickerson
thank you